(soft music)
- Greetings,
and welcome to this celebration
of the Yale School of
Nursing, Class of 2020.
It's an honor to be able to share
in this special day with you
and to commemorate this
important milestone.
While we are sad, we cannot be together
for our usual festivities, in New Haven.
I am grateful that we can
gather virtually across space
and time, to mark the occasion.
Let me begin by thanking
all those watching,
loved ones, faculty, staff,
and mentors who have supported
our extraordinary graduates
during their time at YSN, as
they work to become the nurses,
midwives, health system leaders,
and nurse scientists
that the world is desperately
calling for, right now.
Congratulations to every
single one of our graduates
on crossing this finish
line, albeit virtually.
It's an understatement
to say that the world
was a different place
when you started at Yale School
of Nursing those years ago.
It was different even
just a few months ago.
Some of you had only just
begun your nursing journey
while, others came to YSN
to build on years of nursing experience.
You had clear goals
and an inspired vision
for how your education would progress.
In any journey, bumps on the
road can be expected, assessed
and dealt with accordingly.
And often these bumps lead
to the greatest growth,
a clinical rotation may alter
the direction of a career,
a professor's comment may
inspire a new research thread,
and a project may launch a movement.
No matter how you started, you
are finishing as Yale nurses.
You answered when the world called.
You've handled your last semester
with grace, grit, flexibility
and determination
and you are to be applauded for that.
From here you will set forth as a healer
at a time when society is
facing unprecedented need.
No simulation has prepared the
world for COVID-19's impact,
but I trust that you can take
everything you learned at YSN
coupled with the different
experiences you brought with you
and help lead your
communities out of a pandemic
that has made clear societies
disparities, weaknesses
and fragilities.
The COVID-19 pandemic will remake us
and Yale nurses must help
remake society to be more just
through your work in the
health systems, universities,
and other workplaces across the country.
As Yale nurses, you will
be joining communities
and institutions that
need you more than ever.
Congratulations Class of
2020, we are so proud of you.
(soft music)
I am honored now
to recognize exceptional
individuals from our community
who have been nominated
by students and faculty,
for teaching, scholarship,
service, and research
through our annual recognition process.
Annie Goodrich, the founding
dean of Yale School of Nursing,
was an outstanding nurse leader
and educator,
whose vision set the course
for nursing education.
The very origins of our
school emerged from the ashes
of another worldwide
conflagration, World War I.
We honor her legacy through
the Annie Goodrich Award
for excellence in teaching,
by recognizing a faculty member
who carries on the tradition
of exceptional nursing education.
Each year, students
nominate faculty members
highlighting their
outstanding teaching skills,
professional activities
and effectiveness as a
role model, availability
and support for students
and community activities.
This year's recipient
exemplifies nursing excellence
through her commitment to all students.
During the COVID-19 outbreak,
she recognized a need
for a change in seminar.
She created a space for students
to talk about their concerns
with their jobs, homes,
and families.
She started each stone call
with a mindfulness exercise
and encouraged students to bring exercises
they could facilitate with the group.
As a preceptor liaison,
she has built many trusting relationships
with clinicians in the community
and is working to spread
YSN Psychiatric-Mental Health
Nurse Practitioner students,
through different levels of care.
She is also an instructor
who teaches across programs
and has transformed
the teaching experience
and classroom space for the GEPN students.
This year, we're proud
to present the 2020,
Annie Goodrich Award for
excellence in teaching
to an amazing advisor,
faculty member and mentor,
Dr. Dilice Robertson.
Congratulations,
and thank you, Dr. Robertson.
The Charles King Jr
Memorial Scholars Aid Prize
is given to a graduating student
who has demonstrated
outstanding performance
in scholarship, research
and clinical practice
and who through accomplishments
in leadership of all aspects of study
has inspired an admiration
for professional nursing work.
The recipient has proven herself
to be the quintessential APRN to be.
She actively sought out
experiences in community health
through her volunteerism
at the HAVEN Free Clinic
through her request for
and completion of a rotation
with the Yale Community Health Care Van.
Through her participation
in the gender, sexuality
and health justice concentration
and through her work in Tijuana, Mexico
providing prenatal care, primary care
and other services
with the Refugee Health
Alliances Organization.
She is compassionate, astute
and approachable to all individuals
with whom she interacts.
She continues to be a
leader in nursing knowledge
through her work as a MedSurg Nursing TA,
her ongoing work
with the Minority Student
Nurses Organization
and in her professional life,
serving on behalf of
underserved populations.
And she embodies forward-looking action
as she said about another
celebration, the GEPN graduation.
Our work here, as nurses, students
and activists, is just beginning.
It's a great pleasure to award
the 2020 Charles King Jr.
Memorial Scholars Aid Prize
to Camille Lawhead,
Congratulations, Miss Lawhead.
The Milton and Ann Sidney Prize,
is awarded to a graduating student
whose research in the
judgment of the faculty
best exemplifies the school's commitment
to clinical scholarship
and its mission to
contribute to better health
for all people.
This year's recipient has
produced an in depth exploration
of vaginal birth after
cesarean section, VBAC
in the United States.
Her integrative review,
expose the facilitators
and barriers identified in the literature
of accessing VBAC in the U.S.
Her study of 2017 birth certificate data
is the first large dataset,
state by state demographic
and geographic examination of VBAC.
Her mixed methods, dissertation research,
uncovered graphic stories
of women's struggles
to have vaginal birth
after birth caesarean,
sometimes forcing them into unsafe choices
such as giving birth in a
hotel room near a hospital
that would not let them
labor in their facility.
She found that women who felt disrespected
or lacked autonomy, were
less likely to plan a VBAC.
This nominee has six national
and international presentations or posters
during her doctoral program.
Her dissertation research was supported
by the March of Dimes
Margaret Comerford Freda,
"Saving Babies Together Award."
The Association of
Women's Health Obstetric
and Neonatal Nurses
and the Rockefeller university
Heilbrunn Family Center
for Nursing Research.
Noting the depth and care for work,
I am honored to award the
Milton and Ann Sidney Prize
to Dr. Bridget Lynn Basile Ibrahim.
Congratulations, Dr. Ibrahim.
It's now my pleasure
to introduce one of our
graduating students, Danielle Um,
in the Adult-Gerontology Primary Care
Nurse Practitioner Specialty,
who will address the Class of 2020.
- I still remember the first
day I stepped into YSN.
A little excited, a little nervous,
and very much determined.
I was, however, Yale headed
that my parents bought
me to congratulate me
on getting accepted to the program.
Also at orientation, I remember
twirling my hoodie strings
and thinking in my mind of
what to say to my new peers
so as to not make a fool out of myself.
First introductions
and a bit of awkwardness,
is now something I can look back on
and laugh about my cohort
who are now my friends.
We have all come a long way,
fought for our own struggles
and managed to make it to the
finish line, hand in hand.
So where do we go from here?
Some of us will continue
our journey in academics
following the footsteps of
our DNP and PhD colleagues
earning doctoral degrees,
becoming researchers and professors.
Some of us may dive back
into the clinical field
working as advanced practice
nurses of private practices
or university hospitals
or maybe for working for the CDC.
I hear they’re busy these days.
The possibilities are
almost dauntingly unless,
but no matter what we all
decide to do with our degrees,
there is one common point.
What will ties together
is the shared heritage
and the practice of nursing.
We are all about to embark on careers
that require the highest levels
of empathy and compassion.
We're committed, selfless, unified, brave
and fierce multitaskers.
This is the common point
that I've seen at every
single one of my classmates.
Alongside our fellow healthcare providers
in various specialties,
we tested our strengths
during these unprecedented times
with the COVID-19 pandemic.
We volunteered at local clinics.
We work long, seemingly
hopeless shifts in the ICU.
We helped with hotline calls
from terrified potential patients.
We video chatted our friends and family
her questions
and concerns about possible symptoms.
We came together as a community
to get their commencement cancellations.
We shared resources and knowledge,
and reached out to one another.
Through it all, we have become more aware
of what's at stake
and we have proved resilient
and knit together even closer.
We're the grassroots, we're the heartbeat,
we're the frontline
warriors, the mast army.
As Yale nurses, may we never
forget where we started,
where we come from.
Let us also not forget our sense of pride
and this honorable call of duty
that fills us all with fire, today.
More than ever, the field
of nursing has become vital
in healthcare
and the demand for nursing professionals
in the United States alone,
is expected to increase
drastically in the coming years.
We're facing our time when our expertise
and dedication, is desperately
needed at hospitals
and clinics all over the world.
And now it is our turn to step up
and fully embrace these responsibilities.
As we go out into the real world,
with all training wheels off,
may we not be afraid to step
out of our comfort zones,
may we be willing to work
in underserved communities
and may we never forget why YSN's mission,
"Better health for all people."
I like to close by giving
thanks to where they are do.
First, to our amazing YSN staff
who put up with our endless
emails and questions
and solves all of our difficulties,
to our professors who
have guided us so far
and taught us what it takes
to become a true Yale nurse.
To our family and loved ones,
thank you, for your
unconditional love and support.
We would not have been able
to do this without you.
And to our peers, who pushed
and motivated each other
to keep faith in the vision
and trust the process.
In the future, when we look
back at our time at YSN,
from texting your friend every morning
asking them what classroom to go to,
forgetting your student ID
to get into the building,
talking about what our future
holds for us in the hub,
celebrating the end of every semester
and studying in the study
rooms for hours on end.
I hope that those memories bring you joy
and most importantly, I
hope they keep you grounded
and motivate you to work
together, appreciate others
and learn more in order
to be the best you can be
for your patients.
As someone quoted Nightingale,
on the white board, on
the ground floor of YSN,
“let us never consider
ourselves finished nurses
for we must be learning all of our lives.”
Thank you for listening,
and deepest congratulations
to us, the Class of 2020
- Thank you everyone, for joining us today
to celebrate our graduates,
brave and fierce.
Please join me in a toast
to congratulate them
on this special passage
and to wish them our heartfelt best
in all their future endeavors.
We're so proud of you
and look forward to everything
you will share with the world,
a world ready for healing.
- Congratulations!
Congratulations, Yale
Nursing Class of 2020,
so happy for you to reach this milestone
and I want you to know
that I'm sending you my
happiness from wherever you are,
all corners of the world
celebrating that we are with you
and we are so excited about all
the remarkable contributions
that you're gonna make to
this world, lots of love.
- Congratulations, Yale
Acute Care NP graduates,
woo!
- Woo!
Hello, this is Erin McMahon
from the midwifery specialty,
saying congratulations,
to the Class of 2020.
We're so proud of you
and all the hard work that you have put in
over the last few years.
Demonstrating your strength, resilience,
and commitment to patient care.
I wanna thank you for allowing me
to share my passion for midwifery
and nursing with you
and for the opportunity
to learn alongside of you.
We're so excited to see the great things
that this class is going to do.
Congratulations
- From the grounds of Yale campus,
congratulations Yale
nurses of 2020, you did it,
you deserve this moment.
I want you to remember three things.
When you're taking care of
patients and communities,
you do it with passion and compassion.
that is the Yale way.
Number two, please take care of yourself,
that is so important in being a nurse.
And number three, you'll
always be a Yale nurse.
Keep in touch, congratulations everyone.
- [Both] Congratulations,
Yale Acute care NP grads, woo!
- On behalf of the faculty
of the Yale School of Nursing
and the Graduate School
of Arts and Sciences,
we want to congratulate the three students
who have completed their
PhD degree this year,
and they are, Bridget Basile Ibrahim,
and Krista Knudson
and Abigail Wilpers.
We wish you the very best going forward.
Congratulations again.
- Congratulations YSN, FNPs Class of 2020,
I am so incredibly proud of you.
You've so much to be proud
of in this very moment.
Over the past three years,
you've proven that nothing is impossible.
You've put your lives on complete halt
to conquer your dreams.
You've overcome adversities,
you've challenged yourselves to do better
and to be better, you have done it.
I'm so proud of each and every
one of your accomplishments.
You have sincerely persevered.
You've exhibited an wavering strength,
you've demonstrated commendable courage.
I challenge each and every one of you,
just to remember where you
came from, stay humble,
always be kind, treat all of your patients
as if they were your family.
Accept criticism with grace
and of course, never stop learning.
I for one, I'm someone that is so grateful
that each and every one
of you has been chosen
to enter this most heroic profession.
We need more healthcare
providers like you in this world,
so welcome aboard.
I wish you nothing but success
and happiness in your future.
Just remember to always
believe in yourself.
This world is waiting for you to heal it,
one person at a time.
Congratulations on an amazing job.
We will miss you,
but we're so, so proud of you.
- Congratulations, Class of
2020, I'm very proud of you.
This is an amazing accomplishment.
The world right now needs you.
We need nurse practitioners like you,
we need midwives like you,
we need nurse scientists like you,
we need nurse leaders like you.
This is a time for you all
nurses to really go out
and serve the world.
You all are prepared,
you all have made an
amazing accomplishment.
I look forward to serving with all of you
in the field, in the future.
- [All] Congratulations Yale
Acute Care NP grads, woo!
- Hey Class of 2020, it's finally over.
Now, the fun begins.
You're gonna be doing
what you wanted to do.
It was a dream,
and it's now before you.
Everything is important,
but as you're all well aware,
everything is never enough.
So stay open and curious
and be adventurous, the world needs you.
So go, there is much work to be done.
We will miss you
and we're very proud of you, good luck.
- From two YSN alums
- Congratulations Class of 2020
- Hi guys, I just wanna
to say congratulations,
to the 2020 Acute Care
Nurse Practitioner grads.
We're here in our ICU
and you guys are gonna be
frontliners pretty soon,
so I'm really, really proud of you.
I also found a former grad,
who's recently been a patient,
to give you a little talk, some advice
and to sing your song.
So congratulations again.
- Congratulations to all Yale graduates
and especially the YSN graduates
and especially, the Acute
Care graduates of 2020.
My name is Andy Soala,
I am also a Yale graduate
from the Acute Care program.
And Dr. Laura Andrews
asked me to say a few words
to all of you, concerning
we're all held up in our homes
and can't have a graduation.
So like all of you,
you are now like birds.
You have migrated long
distances together at Yale,
you have made friends
and grown, I'm sure in ways
that you never thought possible
only a few years ago.
My best advice from an alumni standpoint,
from a provider standpoint
and from also a patient standpoint,
is, make sure that you treat your patients
and really everyone for that matter,
like you were sitting
in that hospital bed.
Again, I'd like to thank you all,
and especially YSN for the springboard
that allowed me to kinda jump on
and find new experiences.
I wish you all the best,
and I know you all have a
variety of different jobs.
But the vocation that you all
share will always be the same
and you will give the world a
better health for all people.
So thank you very much,
and congratulations graduates.
- Congratulations, Class of 2020.
Just sending this celebratory video,
I'm so happy for you guys,
this has been a long, hard journey,
I know it's probably
not how you envisioned
your commencement would go,
but it doesn't change the fact
that this is such an important
milestone in your life.
So proud of all of you,
it's just such an amazing,
fantastic accomplishment
and I'm so proud to have all
of you go out into the world
as nurse practitioners, congratulations.
- Happy graduation day, PNP class of 2020.
We're so proud of you
and wanted to share just
a few clinical pearls
before we send you out into the world.
- We'd just like to take this opportunity
to tip my hat to you,
and to wish you congratulations
on your graduation.
And you should be very proud
of all that you've accomplished
these past few years
during your time at YSN.
I've really enjoyed getting
to know each of you,
whether it be in sort of the large classes
or the medium sized classes,
or even over in the clinic.
So again, congratulations.
Going forward, one, I guess
thing I would hope you would do
is consider connecting with
and contributing to the work
of your professional organizations
and associations.
Whether it be on a state, national
or international level,
groups such as NAPNAP
or the Association for Nurse Practitioners
or Sigma, whatever would
best meet your interests.
I think you'll find that it's
a way to sort of be grounded,
to continue your own development,
to contribute to the profession
and actually, a way to
make some lifelong friends.
So I really hope you will consider that.
Again, congratulations to each of you.
So thank you,
and I will pass this hat
on to the next person.
Thank you, take care.
- As you move on to the
next step in your journey,
I always want you to
remember how much you know
and how ready you are for this.
PNP Class of 2020, we're so proud of you.
Congratulations to all YSN graduates.
- Never forget the
importance of development
and parent-child attachment.
Congratulations to our newest PNPs
- As Yale nurses, always remember to think
outside of the medical box.
Remember how family
and psychosocial factors
influence the care you give
today and tomorrow.
Congratulations.
- Hello, new PNPs, it's a great honor
and a great privilege to
be a nurse practitioner
and to establish relationships
with the families
and children,
and to follow them all along the way
through the good times
and the more difficult times.
So I wish you all well
on this next adventure.
I'd like you to enjoy every moment
- Hey everyone, congratulations.
Really proud of everyone.
Just remember to read an article a day.
- My Pearl for all of you
is that 80% of your physical assessment
comes from observation
and you've gotta get what you
can get, when you can get it.
I'm so excited for all of you,
you will have a wonderful life
and pediatric nurse practitioning
and I can't wait to share
patients with you in the future.
- Congratulations PNPs,
you have an important job ahead of you.
Frederick Douglass said it best,
"It's easier to build strong
children than to repair adults.”
- Nice throw.
So not to worry,
this isn't part three
of your adolescent exam.
My clinical pearl would be to make sure
that you make every clinical service
that you work with adolescent friendly
and remember that continuity truly matters
in building trusted relationships
with your adolescent patients
and their families,
good luck to all of you.
- [Both] Congratulations, Yale
Acute Care Nurse Practitioner
on your graduation
- Particularly Valeria St. Laurent
- Hi Class of 2020, I have so
much gratitude for each of you
and the learning that we have
done together these last years
and gratitude for the
ways you have inspired
and supported me to be a better teacher
and leader
and I am wishing you so much support
as you enter the world
now as nurse practitioners
and midwives.
And become the champions
of health and justice
that I know that you can be,
and that you already are.
Congratulations.
- Congratulations, to the Class of 2020.
I just wanted to share a few thoughts
as you start your journey.
You know, preparing nurses is different
than preparing students
for other kinds of work.
There's an ethos conveyed,
because nursing is more than a job,
it's a mission
and a way of looking at the world.
I've enjoyed watching
as each of you have taken on this ethos.
Now I wish you the courage
to be the advanced practice nurse
you have worked so hard to become
and I wish you the grace
to flow with the ripples
that will come our way in the future.
We wish that you will travel places
and see things,
and meet people,
and do things you've never
imagined you would do.
And most of all,
we hope that you continue
to follow our mission
of bringing better health to all people.
And what do I wish for us?
Well, that you let us
know what you're up to,
when you visit New Haven,
that you stop in to say hello
or you could message us
just to stay in touch.
Congratulations.
The psych mental health faculty
send all of our best wishes to all of you.
- [All] Congratulations, woo!
- To the 2020 graduates
of Yale university's Doctor
of Nursing Practice Program
in Healthcare Leadership
Systems and Policy,
the faculty and I wish you our warmest
and most celebratory congratulations.
You are now among the 3% of
nurses in the United States
who take their place at the
highest levels of leadership
in our healthcare system.
On that note,
and as our program motto says,
you are now truly, today's leaders
who will go on to create the
healthcare system of tomorrow
and we couldn't be proud
of you, congratulations.
- To the class of 2020 congratulations
from the Clinical Support Unit.
- You should be proud of
all the accomplishments
you have made over the
past two to three years.
- And while this semester has
been anything but ordinary,
neither are you.
- As you embark on your
new clinical career,
we wish you all the best.
- We can't wait to see the
amazing things you will do
- And we can't wait to have you back
to help educate a future Yale nurse.
- [All] Congratulations.
- Hello everyone, congratulations
on your graduation.
I'm so excited for you
and I'm so excited to see the next step
that you're going to
take into your careers.
I know that you're gonna do amazing things
and I can't wait to see what's
up next for you, best wishes
(soft music)
- To each and every one of
you graduating this year,
we're so proud of you.
Everyone here at YSN
has been rooting for you
and we couldn't be happier for you
at this time of celebration.
We know you're gonna go far
and you're gonna have
every success in the world.
It's a time to pop back cork
and enjoy the celebration, cheers.
(soft music)